[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans le 7-8
week-end sur tv 78 de votre émission qui
concentrent actualité et idées de
sorties nous sommes le vendredi 17
septembre voici le sommaire
ils sont plus de 3 millions en france
les indépendants vont bénéficier d'un
plan gouvernemental 20 mesures pour plus
de simplicité de protection de ce statut
ce jeudi le ministre de l'économie bruno
le maire est venu présenter le plan à
des chefs d'entreprise à saint germain
en laye la semaine européenne de la
mobilité vient de débuter se déroule
jusqu'au 22 septembre à cette occasion
saint-quentin-en-yvelines met à
l'honneur ses modes de déplacement
alternatifs au gré de challenge et
d'animation on en parle avec jean
baptiste à monique 10 président de
l'agglomération
et puis comme d'habitude nos idées de
sorties pour ce week end marqué par les
journées du patrimoine petit tour
notamment du côté du musée maurice denis
qui rouvre ses portes après trois ans de
travaux et ce sera dans la deuxième
partie de cette émission avec bixente
mayence anti steban bonjour bixente
jianwei un programme chargé en ce
week-end des journées du patrimoine oui
avec notamment une petite visite
insolite du côté de la bièvre de la
bièvre du côté de la ville de jouy en
josas et ce sera tout à l'heure dans le
7-8 week-end
mais l'actualité d'abord avec cette
annonce d' emmanuel macron ce jeudi un
plan pour les travailleurs indépendants
va être déployée par le gouvernement
dans la foulée de cette annonce bruno le
maire et alain griset sont venus à saint
germain en laye au menu de ce
déplacement du ministre de l'économie et
du ministre délégué aux pme une
rencontre avec des chefs d'entreprise
pour expliquer les vingt mesures de ce
plan céline charles et bixente mejia
senti stepan un plan indépendant pour
créer un cadre juridique social et
fiscal plus simple et plus protecteur
pour les trois millions d' indépendants
en france c'est ce qu'a annoncé le
président de la république emmanuel
macron jeudi matin à l'issue de cette
annonce pour une eau le maire et alain
grise et se sont rendus à saint germain
en laye pour rencontrer des
professionnels indépendants touchés par
la crise sanitaire c'est pas parce qu'on
est indépendant on doit pas être protégé
dans son activité économique donc les
mesures qui ont été annoncées sur
l'assurance chômage sur les reprises sur
la saisie du patrimoine personnel ce
sont des protections que nous apportons
aux indépendants il est venu non pas
distant ciel non pas en vidéo mais voir
comment les choses se passent donc on
est ravis qu'il soit là qu'ils se
rendent compte par lui-même du
redémarrage de l'économie et de la
relance favoriser la transmission de
l'entreprise protéger le patrimoine
personnel ou encore faciliter l'accès à
l'assurance chômage les vents mesures du
plan ont été détaillées aux
entrepreneurs présents je pense qu'il ya
un travail de plus long terme que nous
avons voulu faire avec le présent la
république qui était annoncé ce matin
pour soutenir les indépendants dans les
années qui viennent et régler un certain
nombre de difficultés qu'ils restaient
les difficultés indépendante importante
pour tous les indépendants
difficulté sur le recrutement
difficultés parce qu'il ya encore des
choses qui sont trop complexes des
formulaires 30 complexe l'occasion aussi
d'aller à la rencontre des commerçants
et artisans de la ville qui comporte
plus de 800 commerces pour expliquer
concrètement le plan aux plus concernées
jouent vous transmettrez votre affaire
où j'aurai une défiscalisation qui est
plus élevé que ce qui existait
auparavant et votre repreneur studio
s'est trouvé de repreneur le sujet le
repreneur et pourra lui dire qu'il faut
va pouvoir amortir un champion de
commerce sur ses recherches dans les
années à venir toutes les mesures
annoncées seront applicables dès janvier
2022 selon l'exécutif
le nous revenons à présent dans cette
émission sur l'une des principales
informations politiques de la semaine
dans les yvelines et c'est avec wilfrid
rifi qui m'a rejoint en plateau
rédacteur en chef de tv 78 bonjour
wilfried bonjour grégory nous allons
nous arrêter à tra pour vous le savez
les élections municipales ont finalement
été annulées par le conseil d'état qui a
jugé illégal je cite des actions de
propagande menée par le vainqueur du
scrutin ali rabais et c'était à la fin
du mois d'août la nouvelle élection aura
lieu en octobre alors pourquoi en parler
maintenant tout simplement parce qu'un
coup de théâtre vient de rythmer cette
campagne l'ancien maire de gauche de la
commune entre 2001 et 2020 guy malandain
a annoncé une alliance avec le
conseiller régional d'ile-de-france lio
tenants de valérie pécresse othman nasro
une situation qui interpelle jusque dans
les plus hautes sphères nationales hier
jean luc mélenchon ou y est allé de son
tweet pour commenter la situation et
demande à anne hidalgo de condamner
l'alliance du ps et de la droite alors
pourquoi une telle alliance vous allez
me le demander et bien tout simplement
un petit rappel l'an dernier à l'ira
baer ancien adjoint de guy malandain
protégés de benoît hamon décide de se
présenter aux élections sous l'étiquette
de génération et guy malandain est un
ancien membre du parti socialiste ils
crient à la trahison il brigue lui aussi
un nouveau mandat après dix neuf ans à
la tête de la commune il n'arrive qu'à
la troisième place derrière othman
nasrullah campagne a été violence
tensions entre les anciens alliés
tension aussi avec les autres candidats
on se souvient ici du débat difficile
que nous avions organisée entre eux
voilà comment à guy malandain justifie
son alliance avec othman nasro
aujourd'hui nous formons une liste
républicaine
démocratique c'est honnête nous sommes
trois quel d'olive si je suis de la dîme
allant d'un pèse ses mots on tant les
mots république un honnête cette
nouvelle campagne jusqu'au scrutin qui
se tiendra le rappellent les 10 et 17
octobre s'annonce donc haut tout aussi
virulente 1 que l'année dernière autant
virulente c'est effectivement qu'on
puisse dire une nouvelle étape a même
été franchie avec la publication d'un
article de valeurs actuelles intitulé
incurie clientélisme communautarisme
enquêtes et révélations sur le maire
déchu de trappes pendant son court
passage finalement en tant que maire ali
rabais est accusé de népotisme de
favoritisme de clientélisme de
communautarisme est les témoignages sont
anonymes mais viendrait aussi bien de
ses proches que de ses ennemis écoutez
le journaliste auteur de cette enquête a
mûri brûlé on a été contacté il ya déjà
plusieurs mois hardier personnels
municipaux et à partir de là donc nous
avons creusé nous avons attaqué plus
d'une trentaine de personnes
donc à la fois personnels municipaux et
élus locaux des deux bords évidemment
qui nous ont donc raconter les coulisses
de ce mandat l'écrasante majorité des
personnes qui ont accepté de nous
répondre ont refusé quand les sites
qu'on donne leur nom encore moelleux le
poste qu'ils occupent au sein de la
mairie est que ça de l'employé de base
jusqu'aux cadres supérieurs y ait un
climat de terreur à la mairie et qui se
poursuit aujourd'hui qui s'aggrave
depuis d'ailleurs les pinots révélation
à dire a bien mis en accusation n'a pas
répondu au journal donc mais son équipe
a publié un communiqué sur les réseaux
sociaux sur facebook son équipe partent
de calomnies de mensonges qui viennent
alimenter un journal d'extrême droite
obsédé par les musulmans le grand
remplacement qui fait la promotion
d'eric zemmour et de marine le pen voilà
pour cet extrait de tracts distribués à
trappes othman nasri est accusée
d'alimenter ce climat de tension voici
sa réponse moi je n'ai pas besoin
d'alimenter qui que ce soit puisque ce
sont notamment beaucoup d'agents qu'elle
ira bien maltraité qui ont parlé à
valeurs actuelles c'est écrit dans
l'article beaucoup qui sont partis moi
je n'étais pas témoin des scènes qui ont
été rapportés j'aurais été bien
incapable d'ailleurs de les rapporter
quand il dit à un agent le licenciant
qu'il ya une place au cimetière j'étais
pas très bien cette discussion cet agent
est parti il la raconte à valeurs
actuelles et il a raison de faire et
nokia un moment il faut qu'on retrouve à
trappes de l'apaisement de la sérénité
du rassemblement qu'on arrête de tout
politiser qu'on arrête cette brutalité
cette agressivité qu'on a beaucoup vu à
la télévision aussi si on veut améliorer
l'image de la ville il faut de la
sérénité il faut travailler sérieusement
sur les dossiers qui n'avancent pas
depuis un an et les électeurs
trancheront dans les urnes qu'on arrête
de vouloir intimider les uns et les
autres à lire à bas n'a pas souhaité non
plus de répondre alors pas sur ce sujet
nous avons échangé par sms il a décidé
en tout cas ne pas avoir encore décidé
s'il pourrait être porteur et plein de
pardon contre le journal pour
diffamation et prendra sa décision après
le scrutin il m'a aussi à préciser qu'il
ne voulait pas tomber dans le piège de
ses adversaires est tirée la campagne
vers le bas et il ajoute aussi que les
médias sérieux devrait hisser le débat
au bon niveau je précise tout de même
que nous avions souhaité organiser un
débat sur ce plateau à lire à bellevue
n'a pas souhaité y participer pour jeu
réussit une nouvelle fois ne pas donner
de la respectabilité un candidat qui le
dit femmes un dernier élément portés à
notre connaissance ce vendredi wilfried
et qui vient confirmer ce climat tendu à
trappes c'était juste avant de débuter
cette édition c'est l'avocat de rogatien
bouchereau qui est aujourd'hui est le
directeur de campagne d'ali rabais il
nous informe avoir saisi le procureur de
la république par l'intermédiaire de son
avocat pour menaces de mort des menaces
qui auraient été prononcés par des
militants politiques d'opposition
identifié on ne sait pas beaucoup plus
pour l'instant en tout cas vous l'avez
dit le climat est particulièrement
tendue et pendant ce temps il ya
toujours 70% d'abstentionnistes attrape
merci à wall street pour cet éclairage
dans l'actualité également ce jeudi
s'est ouvert la semaine européenne de la
mobilité c'est un événement qui se
déroule partout sur le continent
jusqu'au 22 septembre et
saint-quentin-en-yvelines s'y associe
l'agglomération on profite du rendez
vous pour mettre en avant ses modes de
déplacement alternatifs avec challenges
et animations au programme et jean
baptiste à monique est avec nous pour en
parler bonjour
bonjour vous êtes vice-président de
l'agglomération en charge des transports
et des mobilités durables une telle
semaine j'imagine qu'elle prend aussi un
aspect particulier quelques semaines
justement après après le rapport du giec
qui mettent en avant et bien le
réchauffement climatique qui rentre
encore dans une situation encore plus
alarmante elle prend encore plus
d'ampleur une telle semaine où on met on
a justement ces mobilités alternatives
oui oui évidemment je sais pas si vous
entendez là oui évidemment le rapport du
giec je pense que même si tout le monde
ne l'a pas lu tout le monde en a au
moins pris connaissance du moins sur la
synthèse et des conclusions du rapport
qui est un énième rapport qui nous dit
la même chose mais cette fois ci
avec encore plus d'acuité avec une
certaine notion d'urgence c'est à dire
que nous ne sommes même plus dans
l'urgence aujourd'hui que nous dit le
rapport du giec il nous dit globalement
que c'est trop tard alors c'est un peu
un rap à propos alarmistes que je tiens
et que la question n'est pas de se voir
de savoir ce que nous pouvons faire mais
comment nous pouvons mettre des choses
en place très rapidement pour limiter
aujourd'hui le réchauffement de la
planète donc évidemment que cette
semaine de la mobilité qui se tient du
16 au 22 septembre qu'il allait rappeler
est importante parce que nous avons ce
souhait cette ambition de porter sur le
territoire de l'agglomération le
développement de l'éco mobilité que ce
soit pas la trottinette ou par leur ego
mais au delà des modes plutôt classique
des traditionnels de déplacement aussi
d'encourager ses mais on va en parler de
la trottinette du vélo notamment
j'indique juste aux téléspectateurs
qu'ils peuvent retrouver au sein dudit
de la mobilité inquiète édité par saint
quentin en yvelines et bien tous les
modes de déplacements 50 ans divine
c'est un peu la bible pour se déplacer à
saint quentin en yvelines vous le disiez
mise à l'honneur des modes de
déplacements et notamment de la
trottinette qui a été déployée sur le
territoire les trottinettes électriques
avec l'opérateur tiers mobility depuis
mai quel est le bilan que vous faites
après bien ses premiers mois de mise en
service est ce que les usagers sont au
rendez vous
oui oui je rappelle que c'est une
expérimentation d'un an en partenariat
avec l'opéra de la tire qui nous a
d'ailleurs lors de l'appel à
candidatures est offert les meilleures
garanties et c'est d'ailleurs pour cette
raison que nous sommes partis sur cet
opérateur aujourd'hui la réalité des
chiffres c'est que nous avons trente
mille visages usagers pardon qui sont
enregistrés depuis le lancement du
service que nous avons trois cent mille
déplacement aussi qu'ils ont pu être
constaté il ya des chiffres qui sont
vraiment intéressants on voit d'une
trottinette parcourt en moyenne 22 km
par jour un autre un autre chiffre aussi
je crois qu'il est intéressant parce que
vous savez dans les engins tir qui sont
développées sur le territoire de
l'agglomération un casque est intégrée
la partie sécurité aussi de l'usagé des
importantes pour nous on a un taux de
port du casque qui est de 25% alors 25%
me direz vous c'est insuffisant
peut-être mais quand on compare à une
métropole comme paris la capitale par
exemple qui est aussi évidemment une
plateforme de la mobilité active et
douce on constate que le port du casque
n'est que de 3% donc les trottinettes
progresse l'ambition c'était aussi
d'avoir
un mode de déplacement impropre durable
électrique évidemment souple et qui
viennent mailler l'ensemble des douze
communes et c'est le cas avec 300
stations c'est une mobilité qui
s'adresse aux plus jeunes s'adresse aux
jeunes actifs qui permet de réaliser
c'était la cible les premiers et
derniers kilomètres d'un des placements
plus longs notamment dans déplacements
domicile travail pour rejoindre une gare
routière ou une gare ferroviaire
donc pour le moment nous sommes plutôt
satisfaits du lancement de ce service
à leur retour de ces trottier atteint il
y aura des animations gratuites qui
seront proposés pendant cette semaine de
la mobilité j'avance pour parler aussi
des vélos puisqu'il ya une actualité
pour l'agglomération c'est que en
juillet dernier est bien le nouveau
schéma directeur cyclable qui a été
adopté par l'agglomération 246 km de
pistes supplémentaires d'ici à 2031
aujourd'hui je précise que
l'agglomération compte 420 km
d'itinéraires cyclables la volonté
j'imagine c'est de relier
d'interconnecter les douze communes je
parle bien des douze communes de
l'agglomération puisque l'agglomération
compte douze communes depuis 2016
effectivement c'est l'ambition nous
avions jusqu'à alors un schéma directeur
cyclable donc il datait de 2009 qui ne
concernait que les communes historique
de l'agglomération les sept communes
avant l'élargissement avant l'ouverture
et l'agrandissement de l'année de notre
admiration et donc l'ambition était vous
l'avez dit maintenant d'avoir un
maillage et d'avoir surtout des
itinéraires cyclables sur l'ensemble des
douze communes on est sur cette notion à
la fois de rattrapage et de
développement donc ce sont 247 km
effectivement qui vont pouvoir être
déployé déployer ses 9 e liaison
cyclable structurantes à jalonner 4
couronna piste vous vous rappelez des
corona piste ces quatre liaisons que
nous avions mis en place au
développement du déconfinement qui vont
pouvoir être pérennisé cinq
intercommunalités évidemment qu'ils sont
associés parce que quand on parle du
vélo il faut parler de continuité
cyclable évidemment les trajets les
itinéraires ne peuvent pas s'arrêter aux
seules frontières de l'agglomération
donc qui a été fait avec l'ensemble des
douze communes mais aussi les autres
intercommunalités le département la
région l'état la région avec le rer vélo
deux axes du rer vélo qui pour venir
aussi à traverser saint quentin et qui
vont aussi compléter le maillage juste
en deux chiffres parce que c'est une
embellie serait rapidement la cdu seule
avec les entreprises réelle volonté
politique
évidemment mais vous dire que ce sont 38
millions d'euros d'investissements
consacrés à ce plan vélo avec
pour objectif de porter à 16 euros par
an et par habitant ce qui le mettrait
dans la moyenne haute nationale l'effort
prononcé pour le vélo est ce qui nous
permettra d'avoir une part modale vélo
qui a passera de 6 à 8% c'est-à-dire
qu'au minimum nous la double rond à
horizon 2030 alors très rapidement pour
terminer il ya aussi l'accent qui est
mis sur les entreprises avec un
territoire en c1 17000 entreprise
implantée à saint quentin en yvelines
avec un challenge inquiet prévu pour
pour ces entreprises également
oui
justement pour
promouvoir toujours on sait que les
entreprises travaillent avec nous ils
sont de réels ambassadrice de la
mobilité active notamment avec le plan
de déplacement inter entreprises que
nous avons sur saint quentin est là avec
ce challenge leurs salariés les employés
vont pouvoir justement participé à cette
manifestation à cet événement et les
grands gagnants auront l'occasion de
l'expérimenté de faire un tour de piste
au vélodrome donc on est très heureux de
pouvoir donner ce challenge tant cette
semaine de la mobilité avec des
entreprises du territoire et on retrouve
bien sûr tout le programme complet sur
le
www.servigardes.fr et je précise que
cette semaine de la mobilité européenne
inquiète européenne c'est jusqu'au 22
septembre merci jean vaz ça motive à
monique d'avoir été avec nous
merci à vous je rappelle vice président
de l'agglomération également maire de la
commune de ville preuve
vous propose à présent que l'on passe
dans un instant à la partie loisirs dans
cette émission 7,8 week-end vous
indiquez jusque là rubrique légal
checking qui est à retrouver normalement
chaque vendredi au programme du 7-8
week-end vous l'a retrouvé en ligne sur
notre site internet 1 www.tv 78 ans
comme il sera question de campagne
présidentielle vincent couronne des
surligneurs il décrypte aujourd'hui des
propos qui ont été tenus par un candidat
un xavier bertrand à propos est bien de
la campagne présidentielle
et on va se projeter à présent dans la
partie week-end avec bixente mais rien
senti steban qui est revenu avec moi en
plateau avec ses idées de sorties est
d'abord une réouverture après un long
sommeil mais j'aime exactement après
trois ans le musée départemental maurice
denis a rouvert ses portes ce vendredi
17 septembre le jardin et le bâtiment
dont été restauré une exposition
inaugurale dédiée à l'artiste peintre a
été réalisée reportage
le musée départemental maurice denis
était de nouveau inauguré ce vendredi 17
septembre ancien hôpital royal situé à
saint germain en laye le bâtiment à près
de 300 ans d'existence
c'est un bâtiment ancien et les
bâtiments anciens s'entretiennent et le
musée départemental qui s'y est installé
en 1980 à 40 ans d'existence les travaux
de restauration débuté il y a trois ans
coût total des travaux 5 3 millions
d'euros on a mis en accessibilité le
site aussi bien en extérieur que à
l'intérieur pour faciliter
l'accessibilité aux personnes à mobilité
réduite et nous avons rafraîchi les
salles d'exposition
changer l'éclairage et nous en avons
profité aussi pour réintroduire dans le
parcours de visite des éléments nouveaux
quelques statues des tablettes
numériques
autre nouveauté l'exposition bonheur
rêver dédié à maurice denis elle
présente les oeuvres de l'artiste
peintre parmi elles f dans la forêt
c'est une évocation de de l'homme dans
la forêt de saint germain avant le péché
originel donc c'est à la fois c'est un
tableau de volupté avec un nuque et
celui de sa seconde épouse et c'est
cette question du corps de la volupté
c'est une chose qu'on retrouve beaucoup
dans l'exposition puisque c'est une
exposition sur l'intimité de maurice
denis donc on rentre vraiment dans sa
maison son épouse ses enfants sa famille
ses parents ses amis donc on rentre
vraiment dans sa vie l'exposition permet
d'inscrire le peintre dans son
territoire une centaine de peintures de
maurice denis sont exposés
la suite des aventures bixente nous
conduit sur les bords de la bièvre oui
plus précisément à jouer aux as grégory
pour les journées du patrimoine
vous avez déjà pas mal hein c'est pas
mal d'animations la semaine dernière ça
continue avec nos invités cette semaine
fanny des courses et isabelle pires qui
viennent nous parler du spectacle en
déambulation la rivière qui du côté de
jouy en josas du coup au bord de la
biesme bonjour bonjour donc je vous
présente rapidement fanny vous êtes la
directrice artistique de l'événement et
vous travaillez pour la compagnie à dada
il avait vous êtes chargé de production
de l' agence culturelle des ricochets
sur les pavés vous avez organisé donc
ensemble cette balade insolite au bord
de la bière pour les journées du
patrimoine pour découvrir du coup loin
josas
alors
alors il s'agit pas spécialement de
découvrir juan jose a ça en fait
le dispositif dans lequel nous on est
venu à jouer nous le collectif radars ni
un collectif artistique
pluridisciplinaire
une compagnie théâtre de rue un espace
public et c'est sur l'initiative des
ricochets sur les pavés que depuis un an
et en fait on est partis à la découverte
de cette ville et de ses habitants de
son histoire de ses paysages de ses
mystères pour faire ce qu'on appelle une
création contextuel qui sort là à
l'occasion des journées du patrimoine
mais qui n'a pas pour vocation à être un
parcours touristique ni de se substituer
au musée nous on est là pour avoir une
parole artistique sur le territoire
singulière voilà qu est le fruit de
presque un an d'immersion mais pas pour
comment ça se passe et spectateurs en
fête ou un point de départ et se
déplacer ils découvrent des
représentations offertes mesure du
trajet c'est ça ouais en fait c'était un
spectacle qui se déroule comme une
promenade donc il ya un point de départ
et ensuite il ya une déambulation qui
durent entre une heure et une heure
trente selon comment les gens se
déplacent c'est une alternance
d'installation plastique sonore et de
scènes avec des comédiens et donc il ya
un groupe de spectateurs qui part toutes
les 30 minutes il ya huit départs le
samedi 7 le dimanche et voilà isabelle
donc pour l' agence culturelle des
ricochets sur les pavés vous avez pour
vocation d'organiser ce genre
d'événements autour de la reconquête
politique de la ville c'est comme ça que
vous décrivez pourquoi avoir ciblé
justement la ville de jouy en josas
alors nous avons
invité le collectif haddad à jouy en
josas car la bièvre arrêt ouverte
cette année
donc c'était une manière de célébrer la
réouverture de la bièvre ses travaux aux
abords de la bièvre sur la commune de
jouy en josas donc il n'avait ouverture
qui est organisée il ya un an c'était un
terrain de pétanque et maintenant ce
qu'ils aimeraient bien donc quand vous
ai dit le spectacle est gratuit mais il
faut réserver donc c'est ça
spectacle départ toutes les 30 minutes
vous avez rencontré donc comédie de
nombreuses personnes pour des
témoignages de ça vous permet en fait de
réinterpréter les témoignages des
personnes que vous allez rencontrer
c'est un travail un peu particulier le
travail de résidence de territoire parce
que effectivement il faut trouver
l'équilibré entre eux on n'est pas là
pour faire du tourisme on n'est pas là
pour faire la valorisation du passé on
n'est ni un musée ni une agence
touristique ni ni
ni ni des documentaristes en fait si on
n'est pas des documentaristes n'est pas
là pour faire un documentaire sur
l'endroit est sûre les habitants on est
là en fait
la place d'artiste elle et elle est
particulière à ces endroits là parce
qu'elle elle est là pour poser des
questions ou pour poser un autre regard
ou pour mettre le doigt là où d'autres
peut-être l'avait pas mis
et évidemment que sa démarche là elle
est ultra nourrit de tout ce qu'on
rencontre sur place des gens des
habitants de des paysages des bruits de
notre sensation à nous de comment ça se
passe épi d epuis du fait qu' on est une
équipe de quatre personnes donc 4
sensibilités différentes quatre regards
différents quatre compétences
différentes pas des comédiens la des
scénographes qu'il ya une costumière fin
c'est aussi quatre manières de regarder
le monde très différente web merci
beaucoup failli décrocher isabelle pires
d'avoir été avec nous pour présenter du
coup le spectacle la rivière qui un
spectacle en déambulation autour de la
bièvre à jouy en josas pour les journées
du patrimoine merci merci merci à vous
ce week-end ne fêtera pas le beau temps
visiblement d'après les prévisions météo
bixente mais on va célébrer les fleurs
aussi aux mureaux oui avec la 18e
édition de fleurs en scène la grande
fête des plantes et du jardin revient
sous la thématique l'univers des songes
entre salons conférences et autres
animations vous y trouverez plein
d'astuces pour embellir votre jardin et
découvrir de nouvelles plantes le tout
ponctué d'un petit concours floral
savoir qui a le plus beau stand début ce
samedi à 10 heures jusqu'à dimanche 18h
notre célébration ce dimanche celle du
raisin elancourt toi j'ai bien dit
raisin elancourt toi parce que pour ceux
qui ne le savent pas est en cours chaque
année on fête les vendanges mais c'est
devenu une tradition de l'association
les amis du passé d'elancourt la
collecte du raisin se fait entre
générations enfants aux adultes de tous
âges c'est une réunion pour un instant
de partage le sommes nous allés à la
rencontre d'un jeune homme jean qui
organise l'événement voici son interview
express
[Musique]
avant c'était toujours premier dimanche
d'octobre avec la canicule
la sécheresse le mûrissement precol sauf
cette année bon il s'est un peu moins on
a avancé les vendanges ce sera le 19
septembre
[Musique]
les gamins coupe le raisin ensuite ans
il y en a un certain nombre de grappes
qui sont mis dans un fouloir il foule
avec les pieds le premier jus et jetés
j'ai grave du raisin il faut il presse
du raisin sous la responsabilité des
amis du procès ils boivent un peu de jus
avec les adultes pas trop et la monnaie
sous l'auvent et bien il ya un goûter
que vous faire un enfant puis après il
ya un repas d'ensemble pour continuer la
fête
partagée avec les enfants surtout
le but pédagogique puis recréer toute
une filière
la viticulture planter les chefs qui
viennent de franche comté les premiers
lui dès les dernières la plante et du
bourgogne aligoté chinquante shape et
pour terminer cette émission comme
d'habitude bixente on va mettre le
curseur désormais sur le week-end
prochain week-end des 24 et 25 septembre
pour voir les animations à faire dans
les yvelines oui avec tout d'abord une
thématique de ville ou plutôt de
quartier lancée par le musée de la ville
50 en une en yvelines ça s'appelle
villepreux dans les années 60 c'est donc
grégory vous l'aurez deviné à villepreux
pendant trois semaines des animations
sous 7 thématiques seront proposées donc
ça commence demain avec des promenades
urbaines commenté pour les journées du
patrimoine pour découvrir la vie du
quartier de la bergerie à l'époque des
téléphones à cadran et des télé en noir
et blanc pour les week-end des 25 et 26
septembre deux animations spéciales une
visite commentée tout d'abord autour de
la décoration pictural de l'église
atypique de saint vincent de paul si
vous n'avez jamais vu grégory ça vaut le
détour
le dimanche donc un autre rendez vous
pour les âmes d'artistes s'appelle les
carnets du patrimoine pour déambuler et
croquer les bâtiments du quartier de la
bergerie à villepreux croquer dans le
sens dessiner des croquis bien sûr on
l'a bien compris lui cente et donc oui
ça se poursuit jusqu'au 25 c'est ça
c'est ça 25 et 26 septembre il ya encore
d'autres animations le d'octobre et
peut-être qu'on vous en parlerai du coup
la semaine prochaine et donc vous l'avez
dit on pour à croquer lors de cette
animation lors de cet événement on peut
aussi photographier c'est aussi des
objets qui nous rappellent le passé la
photographie qui nous rappellent des
moments du passé alors justement va
poursuivre avec une exposition photos
bixente ça se passe à l'espace alfred de
vigny à voisins le bretonneux oui une
exposition du photographe claude chose
qui s'appelle bord de mer et autres
univers quatre projets d'une dizaine de
photos chacun ils sont présentés parmi
eux le thème principal donc en bord de
mer mais aussi autour des musiciens de
métro et de festivité dansante
toutes les photos je fais ch et une
émotion sur un lieu sûr des actes qui se
passe en fait sur un paysage ça me faut
que ça me touche donc comme le disait
cartier bresson de la photographie c'est
d'abord de voir ce que les autres ne
voient c'est un travail un peu
particulier surtout sur le bord de mer
c'est la vie de ces blockhaus qui ont
été construits pendant la guerre et qui
aujourd'hui finissants se veulent et la
mer qui finit par les avaler donc ils
disparaissent dans les profondeurs de
l'océan un travail qui se veut donc
original vous avez pu voir dark l'autre
chose pendant l'interview grégory la
photo est retravaillée de telle manière
à ce que cela ressemble un peu à une
aquarelle finalement et on termine sur
une note de musique oui avec du jazz le
jazz métis festival au vésinet qui aura
lieu les 23 24 et 25 septembre prochains
objectifs voyager à travers le monde et
les différents visages du jazz au
programme elle comité le vendredi 23 à
21h pour une soirée soul ambiance de
cuba le samedi direction lorient avec
sophie alour saxophoniste qui brise les
codes du jazz en mêlant le jazz au goût
d'un instrument un instrument orientale
et pour clôturer le festival ce dimanche
le dimanche du coût 25 septembre electro
deluxe pour une autre facette du jazz
entre jazz soul et funk merci bixente
vous avez fait votre choix vous irez
peut-être le dimanche est un petit
créneau pour mixer toutes les ambiances
jazz voilà c'est la fin de cette
émission déjà malheureusement se
retrouvent vendredi prochain j'espère
vous avez coché la case dans votre
agenda allez cochet et d'ici là bien sûr
passer un très bon week-end sur télé 78
merci de nous avoir suivis
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]